It's like a circus out there!
It's a condom gun, fire the condoms!
These things friggin' STING when-
Oh, real quick, this video is sponsored by Bombfell, more on that in a moment.
Our friend, Matt, invented this thing, and he said;
Hey, you guys should try a couple of these things out, because they're really fun
You can shoot anything with them,
You can even hunt with them.
What?
-Yeah. So he sent us a box,
Dump it all out here, and see what he gave us.
Oh damn, there's arrows?
There's straight up fuckin' arrows in this!
Yeah!
WOOOOAH
Yeah, I told you, you can hunt with them.
It looks like a big condom.
Feels like a big condom.
There are straight up BB's as well, oh, and a tube!
What the-
It's a butt plug?
Condoms and buttplugs.
From what I understand, you can put one of these arrows,
Inside, and actually shoot an arrow.
So that should probably be the first thing we try.
So there's this thing which is like, it's like a-
-It's like a hairy butthole.
You could say that.
It's made out of a whale's baleen.
And their, faces.
There's this, looks like a cow tongue.
just put this in your pocket, you can even put your ammo in here and have it ready
Just be like walking down the road. You're just a regular guy
Walking down the road,
-and then birds attack.
Yeah, and you see a rabbit.
In downtown LA?
"Hey, stop it you rabbit!"
We're gonna need a target.
Oh my god.
Watch out!
Fuck, dude.
Ready for the shotgun, dude? Wrist rocket shotgun?
Oh!
Agh!
That would definitely hurt.
It hit me!
Did you get hurt?
No, because I wore clothes.
I saw these things on the internet-
Wooooah!
Jesus Christ, dude.
Sorry!
These are serious.
I was trying to hit the thing, dude, I'm sorry.
These are great, cause you can hunt with these,
but what makes them way more applicable, is whether or not you can shoout a NERF dart out of them.
You shot him!
What's in that box?
Don't shoot it. Don't shoot it. There's a battery in there, do not shoot that!
Bombfell is an online personal styling service, for men.
It's all fully personalized, all the clothes have been handpicked by a dedicated stylist,
And what they do is they actually scour all, like the brands and designers from around the world and like try to choose specifically what's best for you.
Yeah, your personal stylist will actually email you their selections,
And you have 48 hours to, you know, choose or cancel, or do what you want, you have total control.
Yeah, there aren't any hidden fees or anything like that. They're on your side. It's a super straight-forward service.
They don't make any money unless you decide to keep something.
So what's cool is that you only pay for the stuff you keep, you know there's no charge just to return stuff, send it back.
And hey, if you decide to delay your shipment,
You know a day or week, you have complete flexibility to do so,
Or hey if you're interested in some sort of gift option for a significant other, you can sign up on their behalf,
I think they'd like that.
Here's what I don't get why do why am I the person getting these? Why aren't you getting it?
'Cause they're for you.
They're mine-            [The game of Life]
So I'm just gonna, oh wow these open really easily.
Look at that, you look like a YouTuber.
Finally.
See, I've always been more of like utility over fashion kind of person, but who doesn't like to look good?
I'm a particular fan of these jeans these are great, my god.
What if I, what if I do this?
Button only one, that's what I hear is cool.
Just the one, and this is cool? You sure?
Okay, I'm trusting you Carmichael.
you're welcome, you should do a power pose.
There you go.
There you go, buddy.
So you found this interesting, and want to find out more about this Bombfell service, check this out,
bombfell.com/samandniko
And if you go to that URL, you can actually get $25 off your first purchase using this service,
So if you guys want to get some of those clothes,
Click the link down in the description or go to url
B-O-M-B-F-E-L-L
.com
/
samandniko (bombfell.com/samandniko)
I think you can spell that last one, but yeah.
Hey, buddy!
Sam, seriously, don't do that.
SERIOUSLY DON'T DO IT!!!
Fuckin' shit!
Those NERF darts sting!
Mega dart?
Jesus!
No pellets, no pellets.
Highest power NERF gun you can get.
Holy crap, dude!
It's a warzone!
Oooh! I just got in, man!
It's a condom gun, fire the condom!
These things friggin' sting!
Got a sling-dinger!
It's like, you just gotta imagine the entire scene as one giant grid, all the buildings,
And walls, and people within that grid should obey the grid's laws.
So, John and Wren. How's it going with this commercial?
It's going. It's, it's a lot of work.
This video's very, very similar to "Smallest Empire"
Basically that means, you know 3d tracking all these drone shots,
Populating the scenes with things like, buildings, people, foliage,
They gave us a bunch of like, 3D models to use,
But we have to retexture all of the models ourselves,
Which is cool, I like doing that, so that's not a big deal,
But the biggest challenge is just, like, putting them in the right spot in the scene
We have an export that we deliver to the client, and they give us notes on that more the notes that they're like
We want a few more walls.
And it's like "Okay, we can do that."
So we're putting in a lot of walls today,
So I mean we're kind of getting to the more fun stuff.
Check out all my key frames.
Geez.
That's not even all of them.
And on top of that, we got to get all these elements of people on green screens.
Do you have to do all the roto work?
I'm not sure, actually, I don't think all of it, right?
You're pretty much doing all of it.
Nice.
It's all good.
Well, I mean the idea is that it's mostly just keen.
And you just fill in the gaps, because the grass the grass field works with a nice large green screen.
It's just a very poor green screen, but it works.
Just got to like push it into place.
Did go a little more detailed then I probably needed to,
Did a piece for the head, piece for the body.
Oh wow, all separate masks.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's been five hours,
Oh!
It's been five hours since the initial siege, ammo's coming in sporadically.
But, you know what?
At this point it's about the man next to you.
Next direct hit wins!
Fuck! I'm not even in!
*Wren dying noises*
That's my condom, sir.
Hey, you know the things are reusable now?
Go ahead. I got more
You just threw it on my face!
Thought I didn't, thought I missed.
I thought I missed.
Oh my god, dude!
I can't see it. Ow! Don't touch it.
That was a lot of fun.
We're going to keep these rounds because I'm sure it'll come in handy for whatever else We can put in there there.
That's the first time I've ever used a reusable NERF dart condom gun,
But you know, I got to say I was impressed.
*Wren's battle cry*
I'm so angry at you.
*Sam's battle cry*
It's like a circus out there!
What's that channel called that where they lip-sync everybody?
And they do like NFL videos,
And Donald Trump, and like-
Uh, Bad Lip Reading?
Bad Lip Reading, that's right.
Sup?
I found a new way you could organize your camera room.
What- what'd you do?
I'm about to get punked right now.
What, uhh,
What's going on?
What'd you do?
Ah!
God damnit!
I knew he was in here somewhere!!
"Maybe he's not in here?"
Oh, that's pretty good!
Oh wow, I could like feel, you know you can feel someone's presence?
As I've moved this way I like, I can, I felt it and I was like,
"What?"
Just kinda went like,
"Where is he?"
Boy, that was good.
Hey, man, I've been up here for like half an hour.
Did you learn your lesson?
Yeah
If you guys subscribe, you'll be notified of the next time I upload a video,
Which is probably you know, tomorrow, day after tomorrow, today even, and also go to
bombfell.com/samandniko
To get $25 off your first purchase of clothes.